hey guys ryan right hey guys Marie we're
gonna watch the trailer today for a
video game called wolf w 00 l fe woof
I'm sure that's what the game is about a
little dog woof the cuse game ever I
don't know anything about this game I
know as a lot of people have been saying
I should check out the trailer for it
Marie any thoughts I am really excited
for what I am now expecting to be
Nintendogs interesting well guys let's
watch this trailer 1 do make it ain't
kinda inappropriate for children you can
take my yoke this is not a fairy tale
there's nothing fair about it my name is
Red Riding Hood o God have no father
mother no fear [ __ ] she looks like I'm
had this even work accident four years
ago well believe in accidents I believe
in revenge what this look so goofy
where was she taking revenge against I'm
shooting the big
fairy tale
there's the wolf but that's why it's
called wolf I've seen a lot of darkness
but I hope there's a green light at the
end of the town
I can't tell if it's supposed to be like
intentionally kind of funny well or I
haven't state itself way too seriously I
always what this reminds me of India
probably what I'm talking about but
there was this Alice in Wonderland game
that came out probably like [ __ ] ten
years ago now look but the like really
dark over-the-top kind of yeah ik what
you mean yeah no I mean it just looks
that don't look like a lot of fun it
doesn't look like games to date you know
maybe I'm sure that the logo for like
whatever company it was a grin
production that was it ok ok oh yeah
that's fair I mean who knows might be a
fun time besides know about graphics and
we have like we had a nice little
cartoony style going for them they don't
need it to be like hyper realistic I
know it's just the gameplay looks like
this looked like it's a game intended
for children and like the gameplay looks
like it's for children but what they're
going for is not supposed to be for
children so that's kind of what's
confusing about that maybe for sad
depressed children they have a child
abuse team running in these videos right
yeah we really want to see miserable
children miserable children we grow
miserable children ended up fine I'm
just one about a weird off-putting king
yeah oh god no one would talk to me the
amount of cat heads I brought in to
school every day Jesus I don't blame
them trust me I've read it from kevins
if you know what I mean yeah I'm
comfortably close to people well it
didn't know my personal space and I'm
too comfortable with people interesting
oh no no no i think i was making them
uncomfortable what I'm saying oh we both
do a little bit I don't make people
uncomfortable I think I made people
uncomfortable all the time actually
whatever I'm over it yeah I mean it's
rigged it's a Red Riding Hood story I
mean you gotta have a little giggle edit
or two anyway thanks guys for checking
out our video we put a lot of hard work
into it this is the most preparation
we've ever done for a video I love how
you get an intend on yawning at that
time but you just happen d but if you're
new to the chance
well you know what you can do you can
subscribe here to the real rejects
that's our channel we have movie reviews
we have we have um trailer reactions we
have movie news short films and sketches
we got so much on this channel it's
ridiculous I got a vlog that I just
posted my ryan gosling rap song on check
it out creepy tell you what it's about
no I don't want to be free let's just
say i want to give rang Gosling some hey
hey Marie hey Ryan it's been a while
since you've been here but what comes
after the shout I mean ah who comes
after the subscribe button yeah the end
yeah it's so very good bye good bye
a mere zone three not a fan of the
trailer but still watching it for my boy
Ryan talking about me and I appreciate a
shout-out [ __ ] you gets everyone now
ditch this is your shoutout dog tear
your lesson you want girl oh there's
your shoutout thanks for watching thanks
for watching stay tuned another
shout-out coming next will cough 27 hey
Ryan can I please get a shout-out
awesome channel by the way okay thanks
that's cool you that's really cool you I
I appreciate the compliment about the
channel I just feel you could have a
library a little more like you know what
else is awesome about the channel you
know I like details I like feedback
positive feedback I don't really care
for negative feedback doesn't do me any
good but positive feedback always helps
a lot tell us what you like about it
yeah I think people are talking while
we're filming you know how dare our
neighbors live like regular people in
their own home I warned our neighbors
that we be filming at this hour it's
just the nerve the nerve conduction
study of these people get ready to
review watch the Man of Steel review
last August and have been hooked ever
since can I get a shout out that would
be awesome tacular if you get my
reference jeremyjahns movie rating dude
your compliments i would buy it on
blu-ray dude last August yeah he's been
a fan for a while and her awesome
tacular too that's longer than I've
known you really yeah god I mean all the
times you spend together I feel like
I've known you forever Ryan Murray where
you're like my best friend my thanks
dude thanks for letting us have a moment
there get ready to review it's supposed
to be about you but and I would just
forget a compliment t-minus three
seconds jeremyjahns reference that's
what I'm doing oh yeah good stuff anyway
get ready to review its time you get
ready to poop and I've been watching our
videos for a while so it's about time
you go and take a [ __ ] probably got a
lot of things to poop out now all that
because review rhyme with food
look at your channel real fast yeah what
you got here what do you got you yeah
157 subs not bad you trailer reactions
as well who the [ __ ] do you think you
are stepping on a my territory [ __ ]
outta you guys don't hear who's Irish
he's Irish specially the iron and boy is
it you found like a leprechaun did she
sound like a leper go on my boy because
you're Irish we're going to reference
leprechauns well I hope you do well in
the trailer reactions just know my turf
you stay off my corners you guys you
know what I instead of my channel dancer
oh yeah we'll give you a butt into your
channel yeah like subscribe to the real
rejects and subscribe to get ready to
review a good guy he's been there for it
yeah touching my leg goes intimacy we've
ever had awkward